à première vue ce bar restaurant là rien
d'original des serveurs sont derrière le
comptoir des clients passent du bon
temps en dégustant leur boisson et
pourtant l'établissement est unique en
ile de france à particularité les 250
mètres carrés abrite également à barbier
et un tatoueur parce qu'on les quelque
chose qui change
on voulait pas juste faire un bar
restaurant on s'est dit pourquoi pas
mêlé le bar restaurant avec tout ça
histoire d'avoir vraiment un lieu de vie
où on peut venir boire un verre venir
manger on peut venir se faire couper les
cheveux ou se faire tailler la barbe
éventuellement par un petit tatouage
ce concept hybride baptisé copains
d'abord en référence à georges brassens
a été créé par deux enfants du secteur
avec un objectif en tête développer la
ville de fontenay le fleury
un projet qui a séduit le coiffeur
barbier des lieux c'est que dans notre
jeunesse on n'avait rien pour pour bat
pour se poser tout simplement est passé
des bons moments et puis bah voilà le
projet ils n'ont présenté exactement de
cette façon c'est à dire voilà tu te
souviens quand tu étais petit qu'est ce
que tu viens ici bas la réponse c'est
quoi ça sert à rien tout simplement et
et le fait de d'allier gagner des choses
comme le tatouage le barber et et le
bart bass a enfin en des endroits
branchés
depuis son ouverture le 21 mars le bar
tatoueur barbier attire plusieurs
dizaines de clients par jour
les plus téméraires sont même repartis
avec un petit souvenir pour un prix
compris entre 60 et 80 euros pour
l'instant il ya plutôt des petites a
tout cédé flash beaucoup donc des
dessins faits c'est suspend les gens ont
un coût de carrière on l'est on est à
tout ça vraiment cette adresse atypique
prévoit d'organiser dans les prochaines
semaines des diffusions de match des
petits concerts ainsi que des spectacles
toujours dans l'idée de répondre à la
devise du bar copains d'abord